thank you
[Music]
so this story in particular has driven
the internet [ __ ] bananas right crazy
there was a pregnant woman who was
driving
um in the carpool lane
and she got a fine for driving alone
because the baby doesn't count as
another passenger it doesn't baby does
not count as a passenger why
that's what the cop said that's [ __ ]
up oh cause oh she's pregnant how many
months though how many months she's
pretty late she's pretty I think after a
certain time you gotta you gotta let it
slide bro yeah yeah she was so pregnant
that she was she was 34 weeks into her
pregnancy can I also say something in La
you drive on a freeway long enough
you'll see so many [ __ ] people in the
carpool lane buy them 100 yeah
like you couldn't pull over somebody
else well that's probably because they
have um what do you call it the the fast
pass no no I'm talking about a regular
carpool not because I don't yeah I don't
go when you buy the fast pass though you
literally feel like you work for the FBI
honestly like I have that in my car it's
going every carpool lane even when the
[ __ ] Montana and [ __ ] and they can't
get you I don't know I don't know FBI
fast pass it's pretty hard to get caught
for that [ __ ] that's what I mean it's
like yeah it's almost like getting a
ticket for jaywalking that was my little
move dude if I was ever like 405 was
[ __ ] up I just got [ __ ] it dude
everybody yeah but the thing is if you
get pulled over just like Oh I thought
this was the fast track you know sorry
you know well maybe it works for you can
yeah it works for your [ __ ]
Vietnamese charm yeah
you don't have a bunch of
people it's already written by the time
they reach the [ __ ] window yeah
that's true because cat got an old face
yeah you got a little oopsy-doopsy he's
like oh oh sorry officer and he's like
ah it's cool what's a carpool lane
he's too innocent well because the whole
point so the actual point of a carpool
lane was for like not for traffic
reasons right for like oh there's too
many cars in the road ride sharing yeah
there's a benefit for you know ride
sharing so you're like not [ __ ]
producing pseudo-pollution poor
commuting people because they knew that
people commute to the city for work
because obviously nobody lives in the
city and so it's like well these people
are more important because they're
actually working well it was it was an
incentive to get people to ride together
yeah it's like less congestion less
pollution but how much does it suck if
you're if you're not neighbors with
people like that you work with yeah yeah
your ass down sucks ass dude but I also
think if you're by yourself and there's
a lot of traffic and there's nothing in
a car plant if you go in there aren't
you kind of relieving traffic a little
bit by like getting out of traffic bro
open the [ __ ] Lane up give everybody
the link right you know what the problem
is the biggest issue is that people
don't know how to merge that's true are
you sure that that's what causes you're
not sure it's like an anger issue but
dude think about LA and how congested it
is just give everybody the [ __ ] Lane
yeah like open up open it up it's like
you guys are building us another road so
just give us the [ __ ] lane or how
about during covet when no one's driving
[ __ ] put another Lane into the
[ __ ] freeway yeah of course not
instead of doing construction now after
everyone's driving back on it that is
true though that's what makes it express
lane is that you're not merging and
merging is the [ __ ] it's that one
snake scientific effect where like what
you did here is happening miles back now
exactly and that's the problem one
[ __ ] [ __ ] breaks because he's
looking at his phone not even trying to
merge and then causes and then that
activity is just half being way less on
the left side because how many times
have you obviously this is like a cliche
but every time you're stuck in traffic
for like 15 minutes and then you get to
the point where traffic starts opening
up and there's nothing that's stopping
or you go and then there's this [ __ ]
car on fire hire some shimmy all
everyone was just staring the whole time
if only it's usually
it's usually inside just tie his shoe it
yeah this guy's shoes are all inside
it's crazy it's like it's like when
you're it's like when you're observing
the [ __ ] stars with a telescope
you're like oh that star's not there
anymore we're just looking at the light
from years ago yeah that's what you're
doing is you're passing up what happened
wave what's the worst thing you guys
ever seen that like where you free was
completely stopped when you're like a
burning guy oh a burning person
I never see that [ __ ] that's crazy so
This Woman's 34 weeks in right 34 weeks
she gets stopped by the police by for
driving by herself on carpool lane on
her way to pick up her son she argued
with the officer that she hadn't
violated any laws because uh of Texas
abortion laws the fetus she was carrying
was considered a human and passenger oh
that's an interesting Loop that is
you've got it you become your own lawyer
you're like okay let's [ __ ] find some
[ __ ] honestly but take it to court like
the cop is there to just [ __ ] give
you a ticket well so that's what she did
so she she oh she argued that in court I
see and she basically says if a fetus is
considered a life before birth why
doesn't that count as a second passenger
you can tell she's [ __ ] pissed yeah
yeah right she's yelling dude and after
hearing her case a judge dismissed her
first ticket but in the following month
of July a then pregnant same chick was
issued another ticket for riding on the
carpool lane by herself again she's the
unluckiest chick I've ever heard about
and she was pregnant again too or she's
still pregnant
she's still carrying it was the same
lady she took care of that [ __ ]
what does she what if she's driving like
an [ __ ] she's baiting I think she's
baiting to make this point in court well
because they will set a precedence right
so if they rule that that is not then
can't they use that I assume so an
abortion loss I don't know I'm all for
people getting out of tickets like that
yeah but also the reality of it is like
she's not really using the carpooling
for what it's intended so it's like
you're just what is that I'm just
getting a free ride what is that for
stop using logic oh she's getting a free
[ __ ] dude get him back get out get out
of here man
you're right
but also that's [ __ ] lame dude I
think but it's true that's the reality
of it I think pregnant ladies get full
access to carpool lane and the
handicapping and barber yeah don't they
have the sign on the bus where it's like
if you [ __ ] handicap or pregnant like
reserve this area bro because I've seen
that in trains and [ __ ] in Japan like
the special seats yeah well if she
Corner if she got in a car accident
and and like a drunk driver wouldn't he
be charged with like unborn unborn
exactly yeah so and also too think about
all the stuff pregnant chicks can't do
they can't eat sushi they can't do
caffeine they can't drink coffee they
can't jump on trampoline can't keep
their mouth shut so you're just saying
just let them have the carpooling let
them have the [ __ ] who cares can't watch
Law and Order in order okay especially
in Texas yeah
yeah they don't do they have traffic
problems like that
a big city yeah the big city all right
so then let her [ __ ] call All The
Californians went their creative traffic
you know the hogs on the road do they
have to pay for a second ticket when
they go to a [ __ ] Orchestra because
they maybe can hear it they can't hear
it yeah now hey that's small and the
baby is benefiting intelligence Wise
from hearing it's up to that it's up to
the small business I don't know because
kids usually eat free until they're four
so like it's like maybe it's like they
could listen free until they're what
about if you go on if you go on an
airplane and you have like a newborn do
you have to pay a ticket for that
newborn you should have to you don't
have to pay a ticket until they're three
on Spirit you definitely do that's your
carry-on do they get a seat until
they're three or do they just sit on the
left they just sit on your lap until
they're three you don't have to pay for
anything got it so in that case you know
I think it's if I'm Hans Zimmer I'm
putting the [ __ ] screws to pregnant
chicks yeah yeah I'm like you're paying
extra for sure put the screws to him
I'd rather just charge them for
everything what about tickets though
what about everything everything you
just charge them well then if you if
you're a pregnant woman and you get it
you get a speeding ticket do you get
charged for endangering a baby's life
and then they get the baby taken away
from you that's why that's why the
internet's kind of going crazy about
this one because because it's like
you're in your immediate inclination is
to have her back right yeah because
we're like yeah [ __ ] the man and [ __ ]
right and then she's like this is an
unborn person and then everyone's like
okay maybe not though you know what I
mean so then because they're like oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] with like I I don't want
them to ban abortion for in my area
right so then it's like okay that's kind
of interesting yeah that's kind of
interesting right yeah and then it's
like but but we're also kind of still
rooting for her to get out get away with
it right yeah because also if you're
like if you treat it like a second
person
then is it okay to drive with the baby
in a lap that was born oh is that
against but it's on your person so it's
different well she's not gonna have to
worry about it anymore because good news
she gave birth to her baby now she could
use that [ __ ] now she could be in the
car but she's still getting carpool
getting the car pulled in by herself she
gets a speeding ticket she leaves the
baby at home and goes in carpooling yeah
she goes check it out I got jizz in my
mouth is about to happen about to have a
baby see she's in my mouth
that's interesting yeah I just got
creampied five minutes ago so consider
it a baby
what's a Bart you could get pregnant if
you got juice in your mouth
[Laughter]
oh okay she finger bangs herself a
little bit with after after finger
[ __ ] her mouth oh okay that makes
sense thank you we got things figured
out that's how babies are made we're
practically athletes we had a lawyer on
our show so that was kind of crazy